what up space fam golson here from anime
upper and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest
developments in the one piece story
today we got zorro vs king conclusion
luffy vs kaido and much more so make
sure to stay tuned for this one if you
do enjoy seeing these one-piece reviews
and want to keep them coming channel the
pirate king within and smash that like
button with no mercy remember smashing
that like button is pirate king energy
and passing is orochi energy so choose
wisely if you haven't make this the
video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates and while
you wait for the next one-piece chapter
to drop feel free to check out my huge
and growing one-piece playlist that
includes videos called the yonko admiral
supernova and much more link to that is
in the description now without further
ado let's jump into it spoilers and all
this chapter is called bushido is the
way of death which is a quote taken from
a guide to being a warrior samurai and
although we tend to respect people who
are ready to face down death in the
pursuit of their principles and dreams
it's interesting how they play with the
concept in this chapter but more on that
later our boy zorro has done the
impossible arzoro the dude we watched
since back when he was luffy's only
crewmate just beat king the strongest
creature's right hand man the yonko
commander with the highest known bounty
it just feels surreal this is actually
happening and it's crazy the narrator
says zorro clipped king's wings which is
pretty epic from our perspective since
we back zorro but pretty sad for king at
the same time and they've done a good
job of making us sympathize with him
through the flashbacks king remembers a
conversation with kaido where he said he
believed kaido was joy boy king said it
doesn't matter what kaido does he owes
his life to him he tells kaido to keep
being the strongest and he'll make sure
to never lose until kaido is the king of
the pirates and it's genuinely a bit sad
that he couldn't keep his promise you
can tell that king's a solid dude and
lives by his principles so it isn't just
a purely satisfying defeat like when
sanji beat up queen who has such a
hateable personality and let's keep in
mind king did a good job he was clearly
significantly younger in the flashbacks
and now he's 47 years old in his defense
he gave kaido plenty of time to become
the pirate king so he shouldn't feel too
bad about his loss it's just crazy that
he lost to an up-and-coming 21 year old
imagine zorro at 47 it's actually insane
how well the straw hats are doing based
on their ages we then get king's
backstory juxtaposed to zorro's
backstory when zorro lost and promised
to never lose again and ask the king of
the pirates aka luffy if he had a
problem with that luffy laughed and said
nope oda is doing a good job here of
showing that even though arzoro got to
keep his promise it also meant another
person another solid dude failing to
keep his it's the harsh reality that on
the path to be the best there will be
many people whose dreams get crushed and
zorro is so cool here he says if this is
what it takes he'll become the king of
hell to fulfill his promise and reach
his dream it's interesting that our main
character is associated with hell here
while the antagonist king looks like a
fallen or defeated angel he cut down but
it goes well with one piece and how
luffy also insists that he's not the
good guy he's a pirate who does what he
wants to do anyways zorro despite just
beating the yonko commander still has
enough energy to launch a powerful
attack that propels him back onto the
island shocking and very hyped stuff
we've seen from zorro this arc and this
dude definitely earned to get some rest
at this point i felt like it was over
last chapter 2 but this was a fitting
way to end this fight and nice to get it
spelled out for us by the narrator that
the victor is in fact zorro no more
doubt about it a cp-0 member hears that
king has lost and he straight up says it
can't be and yeah that must be how it
will feel to the whole world when this
gets out the all-stars and the flying
six are defeated as is mentioned it's no
joke but it's also mentioned that with
those two monsters meaning big mom and
kaido still going those wins are
meaningless and that's a bit harsh
saying they're meaningless since we know
the last battle had hella meaning for
both zorro and king but yeah i get where
he's coming from in the sense that two
yonko could take out an army on their
own and until both of them fall or at
least one of them falls this is far from
over we see big mom against kit and law
still going strong and honestly this is
the fight that i'm most concerned about
in the sense that i don't know how our
side will win i trust luffy i know he'll
pull it off but things are just not
looking good for law and kid we'll see
this is definitely one of the fights
that i'm glued to the most and i'm just
very curious to see what will happen the
whole island about to hit the city thing
is explained again if nothing happens it
will crash into it if kaido loses it'll
fall and explode because of the
stockpiled weapons and if momo creates
the clouds to hold it up kanjura's
revenge flames could set off the
explosives anyways so yamato will have
to stop it in all likelihood momo will
succeed and yamato will succeed and
that's how our team will survive we get
fuga helping yamato by attacking another
number guarding a door it's great
because instead of getting the key as
asked fuga just smashes through the
other number and the door at the same
time it's such a great scene for this
high pace point in the arc then we have
our boy usop shine and this is where the
constant readiness of death comes in
both kinemon and kiku think they're too
far gone and usopp should rescue the
other and usopp hilariously says perfect
i'll just leave you both an escape which
made me laugh but then he does the right
thing like always and he's like this is
enough of this dying stuff the whole
point of the rescue attempt is to save
them and they shouldn't be so resigned
to death and it's an interesting idea
taking fearlessness and honor too far
usab gives a nice and pretty convincing
alternate life view saying and i quote
it may look pathetic to keep struggling
with tears and snot running down my face
but i don't care i'll never stop
clinging to life you have to keep going
even if it's in disgrace dying after
coming this far would be a waste end
quote great speech great logic and it
appears his words and perhaps tears
really reach the two who were stoically
resigned to die just a few moments ago i
gotta admit watching zorro and samurai
and even batman ready to die if that's
what it takes is inspiring af but it can
be taken to an extreme and dying is not
always necessary so i really like that
oda communicates this through usopp here
nobody should give up on life so easily
if it's possible to survive izo agrees
and comes to protect usopp and the
others it's a very cool moment iso is
recognized by enemies as a former
whitebeard division leader but usopp
doesn't know who he is iso in a very
well done panel reveals his back and the
kozuki family symbol on it he's right to
protect the others and tells them if
they truly believe in luffy they have to
live on after all if they live on they
can be of more use to the cause down the
line izo even calls god usa by name and
tells him to keep them safe usab said he
didn't know who iso was but izo knew of
him showing how famous the straw hats
have become and it's not lost on usa
that such a clearly legendary fighter
knows him either it's a great moment
where he tries to live up to his own
hype and take care of them and then we
just get some more updates on characters
like the ninja is still fighting and
it's pretty even and orochi's still
wondering if he's dreaming and
distracted by his komurasaki as the
whole place is about to blow apu instead
of fighting honorably like drake did
against cp 0 runs away i wonder if it
would have made any difference if he had
drake's back and they fought together
but as things are they have taken out
drake a supernova proving to be very
formidable fighters notably though they
do give him some praise for being a
handful thus we didn't really get the
all-out apu and drake versus these two
because apu just ran away and i guess we
could all see that coming i feel bad for
drake though but this fall served to
show us that these guys are in fact
quite strong and robin better watch out
suddenly they are told to get out of the
castle quickly since the all-stars have
been wiped out so that might actually be
the thing that gets them off robin's
back unless they just use his motivation
to increase the speed of their search
either way looks good for supernova apu
since they have no time to waste with
him it's said the chance of the new
generation winning is a million to one
but they gotta be ready if they somehow
pull it off and it's definitely looking
more likely by the chapter we also see
that zorro and sanjay are recovering and
not in fighting shape which makes sense
they did enough we get a hype statement
that news that big like the straw hat's
beating to yonko would exacerbate
everything that's happening in the world
the fate of an era will be decided on
this island in the next few minutes wow
things just don't get more hyped than
that oh it is pretty much telling us the
next few chapters will be insane
pandemonium the cp0 agents want to
believe that the straw hats and friends
have reached their limit but as if in
defiance of that statement we see luffy
still going strong taking hits from
kaido and even dishing out a great punch
that sends kaido flying luffy falls too
and then they both get up it's such a
great moment as they are both loving it
they're both bosses and this is what you
get when bosses fight they're excited by
the challenge and both think it's
getting good the narrator tells us that
these are the smiles of the mighty and
then asks what will the fallout of this
death match be another hype detail
suggests that kaido might straight up be
killed but maybe death match is just
used for dramatic effect here either way
i am shocked by how well the straw hats
have done but also worried that as cp 0
mentioned they they're reaching their
limit even if luffy wins he'll be tired
sanji and zorro are down right now so a
full-on marine attack after this will
not be good they'll definitely need some
help to get out of this insane situation
but that is it for this one for this
chapter one piece is so good right now
and getting better this is a historic
moment for the manga no doubt mvp here
goes to usopp for me because of his epic
speech i really loved it and luffy was
great too don't get me wrong but he'll
probably get mvp for like the next
couple of chapters in a row anyways let
me know who your mvp was and what you
expect to happen in the next chapter
what do you think will happen to big mom
if the marines fail to time their attack
well enough big mom might actually join
forces with our guys to escape as usual
we'll see what happens it's gonna be
crazy no matter what happens we know
that for sure but anyways if you did
enjoy this review and want to keep them
coming chill the pirate king within and
smash that like button with no mercy go
luffy on it go joy boy on it go roger on
it remember smashing that like button is
pirate king energy and passing is energy
so choose wisely if you haven't make
this the video subscribe and this is
crucial hit that notification bell to
turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one-piece videos and updates
and while you wait for the next
one-piece chapter to drop feel free to
check out my huge one-piece playlist
that includes videos of the yonko
admiral supernova and much more link to
that is in the description and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you